and be one of the top six or 17 they did
it every single year and it didn't
matter who was on a team got to score
the ball and be a high percentage
vouchers Kuzma with the pull-up got it
three ball per cow booze month Utah and
San Antonio are tied for fourth with 33
losses then you have three teams with 34
Lawson told me this is as good as he's
felt at over a year well this is the guy
they need to step up and Guzman knocks
down his second three quarter goat
trying to put a little guilt in hard but
I don't think he says details no heart
feels perfectly all right with that
Guzman feeling all right at the
offensive end
Randall cross-court Lopez won a three
ball no good
like whose money while you see he just
jumped over the top of her and the floor
stop because we thought there was a
method of foul right in front of us look
like Anderson got grabbed and that time
whose must solving all doubt
gosh mark 23 years old as a rookie one
of those guys that older but Bates
winning players just like pow Kuzma
another impressive rookie because the
confidence will be there
San Antonio up by one boos ma no
hesitation confident
Kuzma he's inching close to a
triple-double here was 21 points and
nine rebounds six assists losses over
Danny Green into the pace of rolling
hookshot he's been watching that Kareem
abdul-jabbar hook pulpit